all this rage at sarah cooper for
getting a netflix special dude who gives
a [ __ ]
she's not my favorite but who cares yes
yes she's gonna get a netflix special
yes
i mean what do you want me to tell you
what who cares about a netflix special
what do you think what art do you think
is on its way
folks just like when kamala harris gets
picked everyone's shocked
oh i what no he
but she was a cop and yeah
guys she's she's a black woman
that's what they wanted that's what they
needed michelle obama wasn't doing it
susan rice not really political you know
kamala harris was
hardened political campaigner she's won
racist yes she's going to put you in
jail
yes you're going to jail
i don't know why that shocks you
someone's putting you in jail
you vote right now based on who do you
want to put you in a van
what party do you feel better putting
you in jail
that is the that's what it is that is
why you're voting in america right now
which party which political ideology do
you feel better
if it's behind the people that take a
boot and stomp on your face
while they're throwing you in an
unmarked fan to the gulags that's all
that's
it there's not well but the taxes are
high or low
no it's who who do you when you get
clocked over the head when a bunch of
guys come at you
and and they don't have badges on you
can't see them and they come at you and
they just put a bag over your head and
they throw you in the van
when you're in that van and you're
you've got a bag over your head and
you're heading to a black
torture site who would you rather be
doing that
trump or this lovely indian american
african-american whatever the case
woman i rather kampala kakalaka harris
i rather cockalacka lagabo
come come company
harris that's what i rather personally
i don't want trump doing it he's done it
enough let's give
compio harris to chance
you understand
give tame impala harris
the keys to the cell we're all going to
jail now
she put a lot of people in jail but i
imagine that's fun right i mean if you
have if you can do what i imagine it's
it's kind of fun to just throw people
into you know buy and yes
we're going to do prison labor for
corporations that is one but it's gonna
kind of be
have you ever seen the movies where
you're next to someone else
and you're just on the side of the road
and you're doing labor for the state or
for the town
or you're you're making little uh
trinkets for walmart or whatever and you
get paid 15 cents an hour
that hey what's coming ain't nothing to
do about it
ain't nothing to do about it so just
feel good
feel good that kamaranga
harris is going to be handling it
biden's going to run once he's going to
go he's going to go into the oval office
for four years
and then you're going to have kamala
k k
k k har
k ho can you say kaho saying she's a hoe
but k
okay
will then put you in prison
you'll thank her hey
thank you you'll bring your daughter
this year you'll bring your daughter
right this year ago
my my daughter was very excited that she
could meet the first woman of color uh
vice president yeah well of course no of
course of course
my daughter was very excited to meet
the okay okay i'll put him up i'll put
him up like this
okay my daughter is just so excited to
me
yeah and we we sent you her measurements
for her handcuffs she has very small
wrists so
we have those as well but she's very
excited to meet you thank you so much
thank you yes no it was good it was a
good thank you no i look i mean listen
it's just a beautiful time for the
country okay thank you
thank you in the van
clink in the van
with kamala but all these guys that i
like like kaklinsky and all these guys
kyle kaklinsky who i like
but they're always shot they're like
shocked and stunned they they just
really i mean they're so emo about
everything and i i get it because they
like believe in things
i believe in the future it's like all
right that's one angle
but uh and i'm not trying to rob them of
their sincerity and passion i'm just
saying this was the most predictable
vice presidential pick in the history of
vice presidential picks
who is he gonna pick sanders no who's he
gonna pick [ __ ]
elizabeth warren tanto no
you picked a black woman this is what
had to happen
the moderates aren't gonna care the
moderates aren't gonna care that she was
a cop and she locked up minorities
moderates don't care about anything
truly
other than aesthetics and it's if you
voted for trump last time and you're
thinking about voting
for someone else's time kamala because
if you were conservative enough to vote
for trump once
it's not going to bother you they're
going to have a hard time [ __ ] out
kamala
it really is going to be tough they're
going to be like she put
people of color in prison and the
republicans should be like
and they'll be like no no no no no this
is the
this is kamala this is oh boo
she was a cop yay no this is kamala
boo minority sugel yay
no no no no this is still talking about
kabal oh oh come on
was a district attorney who framed
people yes framing
no no no no it's the black woman oh
boom she's a crooked cop
it's going to be tough it's going to be
tough to really get them it's really
going to be tough to upset
the base with kamala harris
kaha kaha is going to do what kaha is
going to do
chopin is going to be asleep at the
switch and he's not even going to know
where he is and kaha
is going to be on ellen and i mean they
are going to be boogieing down
like you cannot believe it